hey everybody we're back again for
another movie retrospective going all
the way back to the early 1970s for this
[ __ ] right here yeah this is Last House
on the Left
yeah which is uh it's a pretty notorious
film Wes Craven's directorial debut
ostensibly though I think I I have heard
that he actually had done porn before
this and this is like kind of the first
movie that he says that he directed I
mean he did do like hardcore and succour
porn later on like with Sean Cunningham
who you know got famous later on for
doing Friday the 13th but so Last House
on the Left came out in 1972 now it's
probably I mean I always liked this
movie it's very amateurish it's very
cheap it was made for I think $87,000
was actually pretty financially
successful ended up making over 3
million when it was released in theaters
it's really it's it's honestly kind of
like a porn film from the 70s but with
horrible violence instead of sex in it
yeah it's weird it's got what's weird
about it is that it's kind of surreal
you got this couple and then this other
guy and they're all kind of screwing
each other and they abduct these two
girls and do [ __ ] up [ __ ] to them and
then kill ya and it's weird because when
you watch a movie you're like this isn't
very realistic people wouldn't do this
but then you go back and you go look it
say like some of the films that Charles
kneeing and Leonard Leonard Lake made
yeah of real victims you know you think
that looks fake too
yeah you know the real thing kind of
looks fake I guess when you when you're
doing bad [ __ ] to someone they kind of
go into a different state of mind where
they're kind of like in denial well yeah
because it's like when you have
something like that happened to you your
brain is just kind of like nope not
dealing with that and then like
two dudes that are doing it almost kind
of like real second-rate fantasy
role-playing type guys it it doesn't
like they're really doing it yeah you
know now now the the video is that Lake
and Ning made you know I mean doesn't
show I'm actually killing them but it
shows the beginning part of the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] that they did to those girls you
know you can find it on YouTube there's
more to it but it's just you know it's
not in the public sphere as far as I
know yeah but yeah it doesn't look real
yeah it is though a lot of that kind of
stuff to rock real to me just because
like I said your your brain goes to a
different place so then you kind of see
this and it kind of has that tape same
tackiness to it oh yeah and but after
seeing like the real thing ago no it's
actually kind of like that it is kind of
like that well I think that was
something that a lot of people found
disturbing about this movie because I'm
gonna say okay it was made in 1972 like
I said it was very cheap a lot of the
actors were inexperienced had never been
in a movie before or had only been in
porn or you know softcore or hardcore
porn and it shows but in another way I
think that almost kind of contributes
more to it's like creepiness because it
almost seems it has a real like almost
snuff film kind of yeah aspect to yeah
it looks real if you've seen the real
thing yeah cuz it has the same tone at
least in those days it's dated you know
to almost 70s oh yeah and it's
definitely a 70s exploitation for I you
know it's not the production value isn't
much better like you know and you know
Leonard Lake and Charles hang you know
that were they were in the 80s but they
were so retro they were almost like
something from the 70s and you know I
mean and these freaks in this movie here
kind of remind me of Leonard Lake and
you know lake in Charles name yeah kinda
like that now I think something about
this movie and maybe a lot of people
know this I'm not really sure but um Wes
Craven even though you know yes you
could argue that this is a cheap
exploitation film but Wes Craven was
actually like a big you know he was a
college graduate and he was like really
into film he was really into
our Bergman this is actually sort of a
loose remake of Ingmar Bergman's the
Virgin spring which came out in 1960
which was actually based on an old
Swedish folk song about I think she was
like a little shepherd girl or something
like that she's walking through the
woods and she is set upon by four men
and raped and killed these four men then
end up at her parents house on her
father's house and the father exacts
revenge so it's basically a revenge
story um I've also seen it compared to
Straw Dogs the Sam Peckinpah film which
it is very much like that
what Wes Craven was trying to do I think
because he thought that a lot of movies
that that came out even violent ones you
know like westerns and stuff he said I
still felt like there was a little bit
of glamorizing of the violence going on
he's like so I wanted to make a film
that made the violence really realistic
so people could see what it was really
like so it would be he's like I didn't
want it to be like sexy or glamorized or
anything like that I wanted to be like
horrible and sickening because that's
really what it would be like in that
situation so I don't know if people like
got that that's what he was trying to do
but that's what he was trying to do and
that's why he made it that unchanging
and that yeah and I think we did and
that's yeah what I said that's why I
think a lot of people are that were
upset by this movie Jackie's house looks
just like crime scene stuff yeah it
definitely does like I said it's it's
still a very cheap movie and it's still
you know has like it has a very sleazy
like porn movie aspect to it but on the
other hand he also everything in the
seventies kind of dude it did though
yeah I mean especially because I think
that when he when they filmed it like I
said they filmed her for under $90,000
and they didn't have like you know
top-of-the-line equipment obviously and
I think they shot it like in a smaller
like aspect version that had to blow it
up so it's still so it looks like
there's parts of it kind of look like
you know the Bigfoot film not that bad
but it's like you know it has that
gritty you know realistic Verity thanks
goes out at any second yeah yeah but
looks like it's gonna have I don't think
I know I don't think there was not that
I know but there was a bunch of other as
well and I should note to and I might
get into this a little bit later but
because this film was so notorious there
are numerous different cuts of this film
floating around um I have the blu-ray I
got it for cheap at FYE I think it was
like three bucks or something and it
says unbraided on it however I have
heard that even the ones that say
unrated on it still have some [ __ ] cut
out all right because what ended up
happening was that like back in the 70s
I don't know if you guys knew this but
particularly these kind of exploitation
sort of films they would go to like
they've been have so many prints made
and then they would go to like regional
theaters they were playing one region
for a time and then they would move on
to another region so there weren't only
so many copies of the movie now what Wes
Craven has said is that he you know he
would send the Prince to like you know
the regional theaters and the theater
owners were so offended by the movie
that they started cutting them up
themselves and so sometimes they would
get the Prince back and they would be
all cut up and there would be stuff
missing and so like they would have to
try and put it back together before it
went to the next thing so there have
been a lot of scenes subsequently you
know and I don't know if this is legend
or if this is actually true but there
were some scenes that were lost I think
on the blu-ray there's one a couple that
they don't even have sound or anything
like that but that were cut out of the
film and then they lost the audio or
whatever and there are there are some
scenes that they shot but all that
survives are like a couple of stills
like from there so I think even if you
get the one that says unrated on it or
uncut on it I don't think that's the
case I don't know if there's a
completely uncut one floating around
anywhere but because because there were
so many different versions of it movie
industry was a different different back
then
it definitely theaters did stuff too
there are some things we just limit
release it you basically nobody ever saw
it yes it was only just a one little
small
you know region yeah Lomo film makers
and stuff right and I think that I mean
that's definitely the case with a lot of
these kind of exploitation films and you
know it so many years have gone by now
that it's like you don't even know like
what the original movie was supposed to
look like or even you know I think man
owes hands of fate really wasn't seen
when that just scene no that was just
yeah because he was just from taxes yeah
and I think it got honestly I think
Mystery Science Theater was responsible
for that movie that's excellent movie
getting like a much wider audience
because I don't think anyone would've
really known much about it it's an
excellent movie when it has riffing over
the top of it it is it's not on its own
well I think I've mentioned this before
but I would love to see somebody with
the budget like kind of redo that
because I think it's a good idea I like
the other ideas I like the idea of it I
just think it wasn't executed all that
well because they didn't have the money
yeah or the know-how or anything kind of
both but it but it still had kind of a
vibe that I was kind of into it was a
germ of a good idea
Besame dose hands of feet hands hands of
fate yeah hands hands of fate hands
hands hands hands no hands of fate like
jazz hands but yeah it doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense yeah all right so um let's
talk a little bit about the plot of Last
House on the left now
you know like I said it's very
straightforward there's a girl named
Mary Collingwood and it's like I think
it's her 17th birthday and her and her
friend Phyllis you know kind of the bad
girl they're gonna go to this concert
and the band is called bloodlust which I
love that was another movie that was on
Mystery Science Theater about a guy that
hunted people on his private island just
like in most dangerous game but yeah so
they're going to see this band blood
lust for the mom and the mom and dad are
kind of like oh you know we don't like
you hanging out with Phyllis she's a bad
influence and you're really going to see
a band called blood last oh man but like
so they let her go they give her a
necklace with like a peace symbol before
she leaves now while they're out before
they go to the concert they're like oh
we want to buy some marijuana and so
they run into this guy named jr. now
prior to them running into the guy named
jr. they have heard on the radio that
this dude named Krug who is a serial
killer and
pused has escaped from prison and that
he's running around with his son who was
Junior who he got addicted to heroin
when he was a little kid because that's
how do I guess dad of the year and also
their collective girlfriend sort of
whose name is Sadie and there's also
this other guy named weasel is actually
it's Fred Potter potted Podolski or
something like that but yeah he's called
weasel he's like a child molester so
these four degenerates are staying in
this apartment or something so they run
into jr. who is kind of like the most
innocuous of them and they're like hey
do you know where we can get some weed
and he's like yeah I know we can get
some weed once you come back to this
apartment we'll sell you some weed so
unfortunately it was the 70s and like
someone said they had weeds he went back
to the apartment to get some weed man
and how it happened yeah and as it
turned out when they get to the
apartment all of them are there they
lock the girls in that like they won't
let them leave one of them gets gang
raped and then the next morning they
pretty much tie the girls up they put
them in the trunk of a car they take
them out to the woods but it turns out
that the place where they take them is
not that far behind Mary's house like
the house where her parents live now
while this is all going on Mary's
parents are setting up her birthday
party like it's gonna be a surprise
party so it's like it's really weird
because it's like inner cut between you
know these horrible criminals like doing
these horrible things to these girls and
then these two like parents like doing
goofy [ __ ] like decorating the cake and
then there's like these two cops that
are sort of like comic relief and
they're doing all this like stupid [ __ ]
and so the tone of it it's very totally
like there's a lot of tonal whiplash
going on in this which I think a lot of
people find off-putting because I think
that Wes Craven did that on purpose
because he wanted to show it's like whoo
look at all this horrible [ __ ] going on
and then he wanted to juxtapose it yeah
like with this almost like comedic well
it's not even almost comedic it is
comedic like straight up that goes back
to you know like serial killers
it actually make videos it doesn't look
real because they don't they're not
there's no impact on them what they're
doing really yeah you know they'll do
something horrible some chick and
they're just like they're cool with it
they're like joking really joking in
between each other you know between them
yes and you know like it didn't have it
yeah you know but yeah I think so he was
trying to I mean that look on does that
well it's something that a lot of horror
movies I think nowadays probably due to
where they were kind of like trying to
juxtapose like sometimes they'll have
this scene of like horrible brutal
violence with like this happy pop song
like on top of it
you know those wasn't there that like
that scene in [ __ ] Reservoir Dogs
yeah he was cutting off the guy's ear
and that was playing like that stealers
wheel son yeah they're stuck in the
middle with you or whatever and I think
that's that's kind of the sort of thing
that he was shooting for here now it
should be it should be noted that David
a has the guy who plays Krug in this
movie also did all the music for this
movie because he was I think this was
his first film as an actor he went on to
be in a bunch of other exploitation
films too but he was primarily a
musician and a songwriter
now I'm gonna say right now that if
David has had not been in this movie
like as crude I don't think it would
have been as good as because that dude
seems like a straight-up psychopath and
from everything that they said on the
set they said that he was real a method
and that he was like scared the [ __ ] out
of the other cast members because he was
like he would keep like aloof from them
and like be kind of all stoic and [ __ ]
and then sometimes he would like jump
out at them with a knife like to freak
them out and he so he acted like that
all the time while they were shooting
the movie and they said that the girl
that played Mary like during the real
violent scenes like where she was
getting raped and he was like carving
his name in her chest and all this other
kind of stuff like she was actually
legit scared of him and she's like so a
lot of the reactions that you see from
her that's when we were real because
they weren't really sure like what he
was gonna do exactly because he just
seemed like a crazy person so I think
that that really elevates this movie his
because he just seems like such a skis
you know what I mean like in real life
don't know if he is I've heard he's
actually a pretty nice dude but every
time I see him in a movie he just comes
across as like such a realistic
psychopath
that I think he really really makes this
work because I think he's really good
actually he's easily the best actor in
this because some of the other ones are
kind of you know now interestingly to
the woman that plays Sadie in this I
heard that the script for the movie
originally wanted a woman that was much
older that was like in her 40s but they
found this woman she was actually
playing one of the Manson Family girls
like on an it was like an off-broadway
play in the 70s about the Manson murders
and she's actually cute she is yeah but
she's like a [ __ ] psycho jail what
but yeah it really it really did like I
said there's kind of like I've watched a
lot of reviews of this and this movie I
think its reputation is kind of like
greater than its actual because when you
see it now it still it's still upsetting
it's still shocking but I think it was a
lot more shocking at the time yeah you
know they they weren't as toughened up
as we are well we see a man's imagery
does he you know doesn't bother us yeah
I mean I think at the time people had
never really seen much of anything like
that where the you know where the
violence was so I mean they're just let
this girls getting [ __ ] raped now I I
heard that and I don't think this is in
my version because my version says uncut
but they said it's a lie because I think
there was a longer version now there was
a version where they made the two girls
like have sex with each other um there
was part of that in my thing but I think
that I think that it was longer and they
cut some of it out there was also a
scene where Sadie the psychopath girl
rapes one of the girls and I don't think
that's in my version I think that's a
that's a lost scene and I think I don't
even know if that one's in and even if
you have a version of it that has that
end let me know because I don't think
it's in mine and mine says it's uncut so
there was some stuff that was that was
still taken out and that has never been
restored as far as I know now the
interesting thing about this too is that
so as I said they do all these horrible
things to the
girls like you know one of the girls
gets a cruise name carved in our chests
they both get raped they both get
Gingrich essentially one of them get
stabbed and has her intestines pulled
out and then after the other one after
Mary is raped they just she goes off
into the into the internal lake like a
lake or something
like to what and then he just like
assassinator he shoots her yes ya know
the creepy thing about that is that I
think the best scene of the movie is
that scene because after it happens you
know she's laying there you know after
he's raped her and then she gets up and
kind of pulls her pants back up and then
she just goes and she throws up like in
the bushes and then she just kind of
wanted she's obviously in shock and she
like wanders off to the water and all of
the degenerates the criminals are like
looking at her almost like they and the
looks on their faces like they're like
oh [ __ ] what have we done well almost
like they realize the monstrosity of it
you know what I mean
and then when they shot her like when
Krug shoots her he just like shoots her
in the back he's almost like oh well I
guess I got to do this now it's not like
he didn't get any enjoyment out of it
it's almost like they felt like they did
all this [ __ ] but that was like a you
know a bridge too far they had gone too
far and they realized like what they had
done well they didn't want to get caught
well that - um yeah so so that whole
thing and then like I said just like in
the Ingmar Bergman movie which I
actually haven't seen even though I've
read several synopsises synopses of it
just like in that one
the the criminals end up at the home of
Mary's parents without knowing that
that's whose house it is they come there
like saying that they are traveling
salesmen or something like that and that
one of them is hurt and they need like -
a place to stay or whatever now the
parents let them stay there even though
you know they're worried that their
daughter's missing and everything but
they're like okay well these people need
help and whatever but the mom overhears
them talking about killing Mary and
where the body is and stuff and sees one
of them wearing her necklace so they go
out and they find Mary's body and then
they come back and they proceeded to
lay waste to the [ __ ] criminals now
the mom she takes one of them and like
says oh look I love you so much and I'm
gonna give you a blow job and then she
bites his dick off you know they set up
traps around the house which actually it
kind of West Craven you know directed
this movie also famously directed
Nightmare on Elm Street which there's a
lot of like parallels between this movie
and that one like including all the
setting up [ __ ] in the house like I'm
gonna let your keep like if you touch
the doorknob it'll electrocute you and
she'll it's stuff like that like the dad
did that in Last House on the Left and
then Nancy did it in Nightmare on Elm
Street so there was like kind of some
similarities between leg and themes and
stuff
yeah which some people have also pointed
out so the parents end up exacting
revenge on the killers in like horribly
in horrible ways and then at the end
like the sheriff shows up and like the
dad has a chains on he's just like
chainsawed [ __ ] Krug or whatever and
then they're all like Oh what have we
done and stuff I'm like well you just
took out the trash that's what you did
but you know that the whole point of the
movie was that what you know what would
it take for like these normal people to
just go off and just go [ __ ] medieval
on the people's asses cuz they did they
like [ __ ] them all up yeah so you know
back in the day this is a pretty
mind-blowing flick I think oh yeah all
the sex the violence then how it went
down but this same basic storyline it
kinda got retold over and over again you
see a lot of this in modern horror
movies that they're the only thing
that's different is that it has kind of
a by today's standards it's very high
it's hyper sexual they're using porn
stars basically forward things yeah kind
of hyper sexual and it's going way too
far you couldn't get away with this kind
of [ __ ] today and it's tacky it's just
[ __ ] very tacky way oh yeah like I
said it looks like a snuff and which a
lot of films from the seventies yeah
which i think was what bothered a lot of
PE it's and you know I think it's worth
seeing just you know for the experience
of year like a if you're into film it's
so important film yeah than an enjoyable
film there's certainly not in justify
it's not very far it's not a fun
flick not at all and it's also to me not
that it's it's weird but it's not that
shocking it's well especially not now it
not nowadays in the 70s it was sure but
it's just kind of it's very much in bad
taste that's really what that's really
what kind of stands out although I would
argue today and I think that well they
did a remake of it in 2009 which I'll
mention in a minute was it like this yes
okay um yes I was wrong I didn't think
he'd get this movie made today oh I
definitely think you could I will
honestly I think movies today are a lot
worse than they were back then it's just
I think it's interesting to see these
just because I mean I love this movie
but you know I'm an older person I can
see how a younger person might not be
into me the whole rated I nag thing I
think that's kind of people aren't you
know people want to see that no I don't
think maybe not but I mean they did put
it in the remake because they wanted it
to be similar and Wes Craven produce the
remake as well they wanted they changed
a couple things up and one thing and
this is a spoiler alert if you haven't
seen the 2009 remake they marry actually
lives at the end she does get gang-raped
and all the other horrible [ __ ] happens
to her but she does actually they do
pull her through she does not live in
this nobody lives in the first one
everybody [ __ ] dies except for the
parents are still alive but all the
criminals die and both of the girls die
but in the remake and also I fit in the
remake I heard that the character of
Krug who's played by the same guy that
plays John Dory on fear the walking dead
gets his head blown up in a microwave so
there's I just think to this movie I've
ever seen in modern terms would be
something like thousand thousand corpses
that way yeah it has a similar kind of
vibe to that and like I said if you've
seen that kind of stuff that are if you
into like torture porn or anything like
that this is not gonna shock you at all
um you know what I mean because I had
that same vibe though to me yeah yeah
that I mean would you know we're dat
weirdos yeah broken-down [ __ ] 1970s
you know you know
doing bad [ __ ] to people yeah exactly
that's basically what you talked about
and you know I wanted to say to you then
but I'd say house of 1000 corpses was
better um that's a film I would probably
agree with you like I said I think this
film is important to see if you're into
horror it's important to see because it
was a very important film for the time
but is it as good is it as enjoyable
well obviously it's not gonna be
enjoyable cuz it's horrifying but I mean
it's not like the the production values
are very low like it's like watching a
porno movie and and honestly it was
honestly I think it was conceived as a
porno earlier but they kind of softened
it in later iterations they were gonna
show more of the yeah I think of the
violence was left him but they were
gonna show more of like the actual sex
like more hardcore type movie and then
they decided not to because they had
guests they wanted a wider release you
know I get away with it back then
because of the way things were rated - I
don't think they had any problems mixing
sex and violence and in pornography back
then later I think there was some whose
certain agreements from the porn
industry that they wouldn't do that yeah
you know I mean honestly I think the
first time you probably didn't care
yeah maybe not I mean the first title of
this movie was the sex crime of the
century that's what it was supposed to
be called and then it was going to be
called krugen company but they did some
test screenings and people didn't really
like that title and then this guy that
was he was a marketing guy and he was a
friend of Sean Cunningham who was
producing the movie and he said oh you
should call it Last House on the Left
and Wes Craven did not like that title
because he's like that doesn't have
anything to do with the movie not really
but that actually ended up really like -
because it's kind of it's an evocative
title which you know what I mean for the
movie it doesn't but it doesn't that it
doesn't matter I mean yeah you could say
well lasts awesome because you know the
Collingwood house where the people ended
up where the criminals ended up it I
don't know if it was the last house on
the left of the street but that's you
can say that you could say that so you
know what I mean so you have some
plausible deniability there also I
should say that the marketing campaign
for this movie was probably one of the
things that you know really
catapulted it into like success because
they had that [ __ ] that whole
campaign of like you know to keep
yourself from fainting just remind
yourself it's only a movie it's only a
movie it's only boom and you know what I
made an enemy chanting it over and over
now there are different stories about
this because I think Cunningham said
that Shawn kind of came over the guy
that he knew that was doing the
marketing was just like oh you know I
showed this cut of it to my wife and she
put her hands over her face and didn't
want to watch it so it's just like it's
only a movie it's only so I wanted to
use that but I'm gonna point out right
here that HG Lewis is Color Me blood-red
which is probably my favorite HG Lewis
movie I like it better than blood face
but um also used the same it's only a
movie or it's just a movie or something
like that in their thing and there was
also another movie called straitjacket
that came out in 1965 that also used
like a similar marketing thing but it
was like that marketing you know kind of
tagline was so successful the variations
of it were used like for horror movies
like from then on but I think that was
like one of the things and I think
that's one of the main things that
people remember about last House on the
Left today is that marketing campaign
with it's only a movie to avoid fainting
because it's only a movie it's only a
movie
I want to say - it's like really funny
because the [ __ ] the Mario Bava film
twitch of the death nerve also known as
Bay of blood which was kind of like what
Friday the 13th Friday 13th part one and
two kind of ripped off that was also
released in some markets as Last House
on the Left - or last so continued
continuing the Italian tradition of like
taking a movie that has nothing to do
with this other movie and say yeah it's
fairly equal yeah by the way a sequel to
that so that's something that I wanted
to mention as well but yeah like I said
so if you have if you haven't seen this
movie like I said you should probably
see this especially if you like kind of
Reaper bench movies it's sort of like as
I said it's it has kind of like a more
quote-unquote intellectual pedigree
because it's based on an Ingmar Bergman
film but it's kind of like a you know a
grind house version of that I guess but
the story is pretty much the same so you
know take take of that which you will
also if you've seen the 2009 remake let
me know because I don't I think I saw it
but it was so longer than don't really
Britt and I just like read a quick
synopsis of it just to see if it was the
same it's a similar story but like I
said Mary lives at the end instead of
getting killed but other than that it
seemed pretty similar but it looked like
the violence was about at the same level
and I've read you know reviews of it and
stuff like that some people liked it
better than the original say said the
production values were much better and
it was you know just much better done
but you know Wes Craven it was his first
movie other than all the porn that he
doesn't like to talk about to me I
understand it was an important movie I
didn't particularly enjoy them yeah my
guess like I said it's not an enjoyable
film to watch even if you liked the
movie which I do it's not an enjoyable
film I don't like movies like this ya
know none of them yeah hmmm I can I can
see that I can just not my thing like I
said it's a realistic yeah not my thing
and honestly it it kind of reminds me
this movie and I Spit on Your Grave I
kind of like you know I kind of think
these are sort of like too similar vibe
it's like I like both of these movies
but they are very you have to really be
in the right mood to watch them because
like that particularly the rape scenes
and stuff like that there's like so icky
and like really everything the right
move to watch this I can understand
dudes yeah I just watch dude shooting
each other to pieces or to cut in each
other like you know what was it 300 and
all that I like that kind of [ __ ] I
don't like you know watching people
screw over innocent people I was not
into it yeah well like I said it's only
a movie yeah I can only turn a [ __ ] off
to indeed you can yeah the right to do
that alright let's wrap up this
discussion of West Bourbons 1972 Last
House on the Left check it out if you
haven't already or don't whatever it's
all a movie you can do whatever you want
then remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you'd like to financially support
show you go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a button in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to make a
one-time donation it would be much
appreciated
remember these here movie retrospectives
which are usually old movies they came
out every Friday I also have 13 o'clock
matinee which three new movies
that comes out every Sunday and our
regular episodes come out every Tuesday
so check them out if you haven't already
and please subscribe to our YouTube show
if you're not already a subscriber we
will see you next time bye